so I'm really interested in what makes a
resilient child so some of the kids that
I study come from growing up in nope
okay I'm gonna start it again again so I
study how the brain recognizes visual
objects and actions that we see with the
goal of building computer systems that
can do the same thing I make a neural
implants for the treatment of brain
disorders immunities orders and
disability I study the baby brain and
how the functions of the brain develop
in the first year of life
I'm a co-inventor of expansion
microscopy which is a technique we
developed to allow researchers to
physically expand biological tissue we
study odors and how different
experiences shape how you feel about
those odors I'm studying the neural
mechanisms of attention selective
attention broadly I'm interested in
understanding how the brain makes sense
of the sensory signals it receives a
trace brain connections to figure out
whether abnormal developmental
refinement of these brain connections
could underlie autism and so we're
discovering and characterizing new
immune systems in bacteria that can help
us do a crisper cast 9 has done for DNA
but for RNA I and my collaborators are
broadly interested in the functional
organization of auditer cortex which is
just the part of the brain that's
involved in proceeding sound
understanding
any music what I do is develop sensors
for MRI to break down that signal its
individual neurotransmitter responses
I'm really interested in what makes a
resilient child and I look at it both
through behavior and through the brain I
think it was about 5 a.m. or 6 a.m. and
we had been staying up all night
watching this thing expand her being
very cautious so we're doing it slowly
and watching every step and we really at
some point in the middle of the night or
the early morning realized that it was
working and it was you know it was one
of those exhausted ecstatic moments we
went out and got breakfast sandwiches
you are delicious we've kind of found or
figured out how the atom works we've
kind of figured out how you know the
planets actually revolved around each
other so this seems to be like the last
major mystery and I think it's good to
say that if there is a concerted effort
21st century should be the the century
of the study of how the brain works
studying poverty from a neuroscience
perspective is a really new field so
it's been really an illuminating to
understand how poverty affects specific
parts of the brain more than others I
just got really fascinated by the fact
that I had never even thought of this
problem a visual recognition and it's
yet something that I was doing for you
know like 20 years without even
realizing it and it just seemed so easy
and so I really wanted to understand
what the computations underlying it were
before I became a neuroscientist I was
an artist my first museum exhibited
painting I made it at age 4 and actually
still hangs in my apartment beside a
painting I made the summer before I left
for college and that was actually what
got me interested in studying vision and
specifically colored wonder the Putnam
when I was 12 years old my mom suffered
a stroke and after that I've always been
interested in restoration or movement
neuroscience this is the place where we
this is the laboratory this is where I
come to live my life and I find it
deeply fulfilling I have a choice I
could do whatever I want to do
this is what I want to do with my life